Did you know that so many people asked us
what a great starter microscope was
that we created one?
That's right!
You can get the Journey to the Microcosmos
Microscope at microcosmos.store.
And we've also got filters,and slides, and
other supplies even this very cool hydra t-shirt.
All of that and more at microcosmos.store.
One of the spectacular details of animals in our
world is just how varied their colors can be.
When you look at birds, for example, you’ll see
everything from mundane grays to iridescent blues.
Birds some times craft those colors using melanosomes,
an organelle that holds the pigment melanin.
And nothing about that seems
particularly unique to birds.
We have melanosomes, and we use
melanin to make our various skin colors.
So then why don’t we ever shine with
the same iridescence as birds?
Well, we could just blame it on light.
It’s always doing weird things,
playing tricks with what we see.
So let’s just say that light is doing
something funny and call it a day.
Except that’s very unsatisfying, isn’t it?
If light has so many tricks up its sleeves,
that only makes me want to know more about the
specific tricks it’s playing with bird feathers.
And that means we’re going to have to start by
talking about color, specifically pigments.
Pigments are the compounds that color
everything from our paints to our
cosmetics, and we see them all
the time in the microcosmos.
Perhaps most common of all of course would be
the colorgreen, found in cyanobacteria and euglenoids
and plenty of other photosynthetic organisms
thanks to the pigment molecule chlorophyll.
When white light hits the chlorophyll, the
molecule absorbs the red and blue wavelengths.
But it also reflects the green
wavelengths back at us.
Which is how pigments work:
they are molecules that absorb certain
wavelengths, and in turn they reflect
a particular wavelength of light back at
us, which to our eyes, then looks like color.
So when we look at these Haematococcus and see
a mix of green and red, what we’re actually
seeing is a mixture of pigment molecules
reflecting different wavelengths of light.
There’s the chlorophyll reflecting green,
and the astaxanthin pigment
molecule reflecting red light back at us.
And so the lesson we take from pigments
is that light doesn’t just shine.
It reflects and absorbs.
But it also does more than that.
That became very clear to Robert Hooke,
who in 1665 published what is probably one of
the most important texts in microscopy history:
Micrographia, or Some Physiological Descriptions
of Minute Bodies Made by Magnifying Glasses:
With Observations and Inquiries Thereupon.
This work contained detailed descriptions and
illustrations of objects Hooke examined under
the microscope, including the feathers Hooke
found from peacocks, ducks, and other birds.
Hooke compared the structures he saw on
the iridescent peacock feathers
to pearls, which, as he wrote quote:
do not onely reflect a very brisk light, but
tinge that light in a most curious manner;
and by means of various positions, in respect
of the light, they reflect back now one colour,
and then another, and those most vividly.
As scientists began to better understand
what light is and how it interacts with
the world around it, they were able
to understand what was happening.
The light was not getting absorbed
and reflected by a pigment.
It was interacting with the physical
structures within the feather,
refracting and diffracting and scattering
and whatever else the light can do.
The result, to our eyes, is structural color:
a color whose wavelength is the result of
the structures the light was moving through.
And for some structural colors, the
angle of the viewer relative to what
they’re looking at will change the
color itself, and this produces iridescence.
You can think of the difference
between pigments and structural color
as kind of like the difference between
looking at a crayon and a rainbow.
When we see a rainbow, we’re
not looking at colored water.
We’re seeing light refract and reflect
and disperse in those water droplets.
Except at the end of the day, a
rainbow is a function of the rain
and sunshine and your eyes, making it an
illusory object that you can of course never touch
or find the end of.
Feathers, on the other hand, are very tangible.
And the structures they use to craft their
colors are very present and observable.
But before we dive too deep into
how feathers use structural color,
we should note that birds can and do use
pigments as well for their coloring,
mixing carotenoids, melanins, and
porphyrines for their various hues.
But birds can also expand on that range,
using structural colors.
The blues you see in these
feathers here are structural color.
Blue pigment is unusually
difficult to find in nature.
So when the color does appear, like in these
feathers or in the wings of a butterfly,
it is often from structural color.
Now the structures that make that happen
are located in the barbules, those tiny,
interlocking threads that make
a feather feel, well you know like, feathery.
Inside the barbules are keratin and melanosomes,
those melanin-containing organelles we
mentioned in the beginning of the episode.
And it's the arrangement of these
melanosomes within the keratin
that create the structures that will in
turn determine the color of the feather.
Now a lot of animals, including again us,
have melanosomes.
But birds are unique because
their melanosomes can be hollow.
And the more hollow the melanosome, scientists
have found, the more iridescent the feathers.
And if they produce thinner melanosomes that
are shaped more like a flat plate than a rod,
the iridescence will only increase.
These features of the melanosomes are essentially
changing the way that light moves through
the feather, crafting a different color.
Scientists are still learning about how these
structural colors have evolved in feathers,
and why there’s so much variety incolor
and iridescence across different birds species.
These are structures that once contained pigments,
but evolved to contain nothing, because being
empty somehow made even more brilliant colors.
It is a wild leap to make, but of course,
evolution doesn’t think, if color is produced,
and it confers an advantage, evolution
doesn’t care or know how this happened,
the photons that would have existedwhether
or not life ever evolvedin our universe
doing a marvelous dance in the empty
pigment organelles of a birds feather,
it evolved without anyone ever knowing
how it worked, until us, until now.
Thank you for coming on this journey with us as
we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
The people on the screen right
now, they are our Patreon patrons.
They are the people that allow us to
keep on diving deeper into our universe,
and as you go deeper, you get
closer and tiny things get bigger.
And then suddenly you can see
things that no one ever saw before.
If you want to become one of those
people and also get some cool perks,
you can go to Patreon.com/JourneytoMicro.
We really do appreciate it.
And we really couldn't do it without you.
If you want to see more from our
master of microscopes, James Weiss,
you can check out Jam and Germs
on Instagram and if you want to
see more from us, there's always a
subscribe button somewhere nearby.